foreign
welcome to Tech news briefing it's
Wednesday June 7th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
this week Linda yaccarino took over as
Twitter's new CEO but in this episode
we're going to talk about something that
happened before she joined according to
researchers at Stanford University
Twitter failed to prevent dozens of
previously flagged images of child
sexual abuse from being posted on its
platform in recent months the
researchers were investigating how
social media platforms deal with the
issue of blocking child sexual abuse
material they said they told Twitter
staff about the findings and that the
problem appeared to have been resolved
in May but the issue they say points to
a lapse in basic enforcement by Twitter
with me to discuss these findings is our
Twitter reporter Alexa course who wrote
about this so tell us how did Stanford
researchers discover these images so
this group of researchers at Stanford
have been investigating child safety
issues online across several platforms
and one thing they told me they do when
they investigate this issue is they
don't want to accidentally see you know
these awful images so they said they set
up a system to automatically detect
unique signatures of these images and
their system started detecting dozens of
hits from Posts that were on Twitter so
Alexa tell us
let's study in this investigation is
about how internet platforms are dealing
with detecting blocking and removing
this material and how their enforcement
is going part of the challenge with that
for the researchers was how do you
investigate that without having to
actually see this material what systems
are typically in place to prevent these
images from coming up so a tool the
researchers used that we mentioned in
the article is a technology called photo
DNA and photodna creates a unique
digital signature known as the hash of
an image and platforms researchers can
use that to check the hashes of other
images or what users are posting photo
DNA has been around for years it's been
used by tech companies and law
enforcement and Twitter even previously
has publicly said a used photo DNA
although the company didn't respond to a
request for a comment about whether it's
still still uses the tool do we know how
Twitter let this happen we actually
don't know exactly what the issue was
here Twitter didn't respond to a request
for comment or share details but the
researchers did tell me that they
reached out to Twitter about the problem
communicated what they were finding and
Twitter told them that they had made
improvements to their detection system
and the researchers also said that based
on their analysis it looks like Twitter
had resolved the problem in May when
Elon Musk bought the company back in
October he said cracking down on sexual
abuse material was a number one priority
so what has the company done so far
Twitter says it has been cracking down
on this kind of content for the month of
January for example the platform said it
suspended roughly 404
000 accounts that created or engaged
with this material and the company said
that was a 112 percent increase in
suspension since November hasn't this
issue been around for a while right I
mean one thing we say in the story and
the researchers note is that Twitter is
by no means the only Tech or social
media company to have faced this issue
and it's a big challenge for internet
companies to detect and block this kind
of material of course Bad actors can
also evolve their methods is there
anything that makes Twitter's approach
different to other social media
platforms well the researchers pointed
out in their report that Twitter faces
kind of a particular challenge because
its policies do allow some adult nudity
so the researchers said that makes it a
bit more complicated for Twitter to
figure out what's okay what involves
consenting adults and what's not okay
and needs to be blocked Twitter of
course prohibits material that features
or promotes child sexual exploitation
Alexa two of Twitter's top safety
Executives left last week what does this
mean for Twitter going forward
particularly as it has a new CEO it's
been a tumultuous period for Twitter
according to our reporting their exits
came in part because of a controversy
over Twitter's handling of a movie about
gender issues that's according to one of
the executives who left in other people
familiar with the matter
more broadly these departures raise more
questions and shine even more of a light
on how Twitter has been struggling with
questions and controversies about
content moderation musk has pledged to
make Twitter a Haven for Free Speech but
how does that play out in practice
all right that was our Twitter reporter
Alexa course
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]